U.S politicians have been debating a
bill that would give the president
authority to ban apps including
Tick-Tock U.S intelligence agencies
believe the video of sharing platform is
a national security risk because the
Chinese government could have access to
user data Tick Tock has around 100
million users in the us alone the app
has already been banned from a
government-issued phones in America
Canada and the European Parliament honey
Joe Castro has more on this now from
Washington DC
the regulations the protections that
this bill is designed to strip from Tick
Tock are frankly the only thing that
stand between the social media app and
the previous attempts to ban it across
the United States of course by the Trump
Administration what this bill does is it
would allow the current presidential
Administration Joe Biden to ban Tick
Tock Across the Nation if it is
determined that the app is sharing
private user data with anyone who is
involved or controlled by China or the
Chinese government this is a
republican-sponsored bill it's sponsor
called Tick Tock a trojan horse saying
that it can be turned to spy on
Americans and there have been a few
Democrats on this committee though who
have voiced that this proposal is too
broad and for that reason they are
opposed to it tick tock and its
spokesperson is trying to defend itself
so they point to measures taken within
the last two years to try to make
safeguards for example storing all
Americans user data and servers in the
United States not within China and in
fact there has been an ongoing lobbying
effort from Tick Tock here in Capitol
Hill and at the White House to work out
a deal and that still might be the case
where the social media app is allowed to
continue its operations in the U.S
well meanwhile China says the ban by the
U.S is an abuse of state power
as the world stops superpower how unsure
of itself can the U.S be to fear our
young people's favorite app to such a
degree the U.S has been over stretching
the concept of National Security and
abusing state power to suppress other
countries companies we firmly oppose
those wrong actions the U.S government
should respect the principles of market
economy and Fair competition well
another U.S congressional committee has
held hearings on what it calls the
Chinese Communist party's threat to
America in the first session Witnesses
testified on China's influence on
technology aggression towards Taiwan and
human rights abuses the committee chair
said that China's ruling party was laser
focused on a totalitarian future
very very ideal we may call this
a strategic competition but it's not a
polite tennis match this is an
existential struggle over what life will
look like in the 21st century and the
most fundamental freedoms are at stake
let's speak to Joseph Mahoney now he's a
professor of politics and international
relations at East China Normal
University he joins us from Shanghai
welcome to the program so to what extent
are U.S fares over Tick Tock justified
in in your view
well you know the fact of the matter is
there's no evidence that Tick Tock uh or
previously other Chinese tech companies
like Huawei have ever posed real
security threats to the U.S or anyone
else rather what we've seen is that the
U.S has advanced this anti-china
narrative step by step in global media
that China needs to be feared and
countered uh even falsely accusing China
of genocide of deliberately unleashing
covid-19 of a communist plot through the
world and this has induced fear that
Chinese tech companies might in the
future be weaponized against the US and
others but you know given this logic
what firm is safe what Chinese company
or indeed any other company around the
world is safe and in fact what Chinese
industry can't be weaponized if we
really want to get creative about it if
we really want to go down that
hysterical path uh consequently this is
the tip of a much bigger Cold War
Iceberg second this is part of America's
broader efforts to Foster Tech
decoupling which in a tech and
information driven global economy is
really about subdividing the world into
respective spheres of influence and
trying to ensure that China's fear is
very small and contained so we can see
this fits within a broader containment
strategy that includes selling nuclear
submarines to Australia stationing
nuclear capable bombers there putting
U.S military personnel in Taiwan
upgrading Weapons Systems in South Korea
trying to advance the indo-pacific and
August Concepts and and still trying to
extend NATO to counter China now why now
right because Biden is very good at
sequencing he induced hysteria over a
weather balloon to create fear and a
talking point where his State of the
Union speech where he mentioned China by
name more than any other country
including more than he mentioned the U.S
and he did so ahead of NATO meetings in
Brussels and now he faces a divided
Congress where the only bipartisanship
taking place is on the new anti-china
Committee in the house in short China
has been making incredible progress and
development while the U.S has for
decades been victimized by its own poor
governance and growing polarization now
the U.S remains unable to muster
bipartisan support for addressing much
needed self-reforms and Redevelopment
instead the one thing they can agree on
is scapegoating China for America's
problem okay so given what you say then
how is the Chinese leadership likely to
react to these kind of issues then for
example tick tock
well I think what we've heard very
clearly from the Chinese leadership is
precisely how they are are reacting that
the U.S is uh uh abusing uh state power
uh to uh overextend uh its security
Concepts and doing so in ways that uh uh
very explicitly very deliberately try to
knock down Chinese technological
development and all uh in order to uh
promote uh uh an uncle an unfair uh
playing field which has existed for
decades and that China has struggled to
overcome
um and we see this not just uh with with
this effort but with the chips
legislation last year and before that
the U.S instigated trade war against
China okay we'll leave it there Joseph
Mahoney we very much appreciate your
time here on Al Jazeera thank you